au départemental 91 lieu-dit la vallée
dans le parc naturel de la haute vallée
de chevreuse le petit moulin est là
depuis 800 ans
d'abord moulin à farine il se transforme
en auberge depuis à peu près 150 ans on
a un phénomène de parisiens qui viennent
se ressourcer
attiré par ce concentré de nature et il
ya donc une époque où parfums par la
fameuse ligne de train la ligne de saut
les parisiens arrivés
à vous les troncs et ensuite à saint
rémy les chevreuse et été amenés en
diligence qu'on appelait pas tache au
coeur des vautier renaer ouvert au
public à la fin du mois d'août le moulin
à partir aujourd'hui au parc naturel une
exposition retrace son histoire
géologique mais aussi artistique de 1830
à 1870 il devient une colonie de
peintres paysagistes
c'est la première fois qu'il n'est pas
un spécialiste de l'aide de cernay
se retrouvent réunis dans un seul lieu
donc leurs tableaux sont dispersés dans
plusieurs musées de france même à
l'étranger
près de 700 fin de son pc par les votes
cerner deuxième moitié du 19e siècle
avec des objets d'époque ou encore un
tutoriel ludique sur la création d'une
toile paysagère le petit moule invite à
la balade artistique ou patrimonial